on continue sur le lynchage médiatique
sur les victimes des médias de plus si
vous restez avec nous volontiers on vous
garde et on accueille djamel bouras et
francis lalanne
jamais pour la foire à l'occasion dans
les murs courriel il expliqué c'est bien
si vous êtes champion du monde de judo
champion olympique de judo confond avec
la boxe très bien et on va voir donc une
histoire de raconter d'histoires qui
vous est arrivé
francis lalanne bonsoir
gérard muller
comment
ok vous admirez le gérard muller de
france inter c'est le gérant miller qui
est tous les jours et coûter par deux
millions deux cent cinquante mille
personnes dans tous les sens où et qui
est mon teint victime des médias
il n'est pas victime des médias mais il
a un avis sur les médias janadi sur tout
genre elle vous écoute mes parents vous
trouve méchant je perds tu veux pas être
méchant mais non bon alors on va
commencer avec vous francis lalanne
d'avoir votre actualité
moi je ne suis pas une victime des
médias donc là j'ai pas une victime les
médias je suis pas là pour ça je suis là
pour parler de la sortie de mon livre et
de mon spectacle au bataclan met en
vente par les ambassades ou su éveiller
on l'a web alors commencer le membre est
donc je tiens à dire que ce qui me
concerne je n'ai accusé personne d'aucun
crime concernant wii puisque pour moi le
monde médiatique est un monde qui
s'exprime et on connaît son langage et
que partir du moment où on connaît son
langage on accepte ou alors ouais on ne
fait pas ce métier vous voulez plutôt
refusé parce que vous avez quand même
clairement oui on veut dire que vous
êtes quelqu'un qui a toujours eu maille
à partir avec
j'ai quand même beaucoup c'est pas mal
je sais pas le judo c'est la bonne vous
avez aimé que c'est quand même pas mal
de photographes hamas de journaliste
j'ai toujours été un peu rebelle par
rapport au système médiatique il vole on
fait payer
personne ne m'a rien fait payer et je
n'évoque ces personnes contrairement à
ce qu'on peut lire dans la presse mais
pardon tous les articles qui sont dans
vos dossiers de prêts ce qui concerne
les bagarres vous avez des reporteurs
avec les gens et ça c'est faux écoutez
la façon dont l'histoire est racontée et
bien entendu faux ça mais je vais vous
raconter la vraie alors je pense pas non
moi je pense que vous avez méfiez vous
parce qu'il n'a peut-être jamais bossé
pour commenter ce choix je peux dire
c'est que la jour jean cocteau est vie
je suis un mensonge qui dit toujours la
vérité
je crois que c'est un petit peu une
phrase qu'on pourrait appliquer au monde
médiatique le monde médiatique n'est
plus là pour informer il est là pour
distraire on le sait est hélas bomba et
suit les tendances qu'ils pensent être
celle des autres c'est 10 du spectateur
et qui souvent ne le sont pas d'ailleurs
et quand on pense que les gens ont
besoin de potins on leur sortent du
potin quand on pense que les gens ont
besoin des missions culturelles en leur
sein du 8 octobre
en fait les gens ont besoin de choses
très saine mais comme ils sont très
fatigués quand ils rentrent du travail
il m'a il regarde ce qu'on montre à la
télé puis une manne qui a mangé ça fait
sept ans par exemple qu'on vous a pas vu
on peut pas dire qu'on leur montre
souvent francis alabert à peu près une
dizaine d'une quinzaine de télévision en
20 ans c'est un choix personnel et j'ai
eu la chance d'arriver dans ce métier à
une époque où le monde médiatique
n'avait pas autant d'importance et les
gens sortaient de chez eux ils allés à
la rencontre des artistes est un petit
peu ce qui est en train de se passer
maintenant grâce à l'avènement du du du
rap du tout les groupes alternatifs qui
se produisent dans des lieux non non
subventionnées fanon avait décidé d'être
marginal en quelque sorte que ça se
passait mal par rapport à quoi et par
rapport à qui par rapport aux médias de
vérité alors moi sous léon s'est
rencontré il ya 15 ans dans une émission
sur tf1 que ces risques ou pas je m'en
souviens très bien
l'avais dit c'était génial maladie quand
vous étiez sur scène que ça se passait
très bien vous jouissiez dans votre
votre j'ai pas dit ça j'ai dit que j'ai
il m'était arrivé de ressentir un
plaisir extrême avant l'ordre à la
banque vous pouvez arrêter avait reconnu
que sa de francis s'est pas retenu que
ça s'ajuste à des nets à certaines état
d'esprit je suis on est là moi je
voudrais plus de revenus aujourd'hui une
fois dans double jeu non ce que je veux
dire simplement c'est que vous avez été
mis à l'écart des par les gens des
médias tant personne alors parlons de
vos spectacles vous faites une comédie
musicale kerber pagani au bataclan qui
s'appelle megalopolis oui parlons c'est
quoi eh bien puisque je suis venu pour
ça je vais donc en parler cheikh s'est
retiré il s'agit donc d'un spectacle une
comédie musicale dans ma très jeune
carrière puisqu'elle n'a que 20 ans je
n'avais encore jamais participé à une
comédie musicale et
elle a été mise en scène est adapté de
l'oeuvre dernière pagani par un jeune
metteur en scène qui s'appelle bernard
bittan dont j'avais vu un spectacle il
ya quelques années qui m'avait
bouleversé qui s'appelait le salé le
miel et donc il a adapté l'oeuvre de
pagani la trouver dans les chansons de
pagani des personnages ce qui est
extraordinaire ça raconte quoi alors
megalopolis arrête conte une histoire
très contemporaine qu'est qui va vous
plaire je pense thierry vous qui êtes à
un publiciste c'est à dire un peu les
mystères non pas quelqu'un qui fait la
publicité ça raconte l'histoire d'un
monde qui consensuel qui s'enferre dans
le dans les haras dans les banlieues le
marasme de la pensée unique c'est à dire
vous savez on n'est plus dans un monde
totalitaire aujourd'hui où le pouvoir
s'exerce par la violence armée
on est dans un monde subliminal où la
violence s'exerce par la dialectique
très simple qui est seule nouvelle
ternes ans de la caresse avec une
manipulation médiatique qui tend à
culpabiliser celui qui ne pense pas la
même chose que la majorité va grimper
pas souvent à la télé mais quand vous
menez à bien après sa finale à mais
celle très bien le seul mot que je veux
dire si vous le permettez chemins j en
fais c'est que l'expression de cette
bien team c'est à dire de la relation
amoureuse qui pratiquent entre eux où la
relation d'amitié l'équipe at-il
pratique entre eux et bien s'est
présenté comme étant finalement
aujourd'hui la réponse au pouvoir
vertical je crois que plusieurs villes
intime plus envie d'amitié plus envie
d'amour personnel et plus on rebelles
voilà ce que raconte cette histoire j'ai
envie là ça vous branche pas voir cette
pièce
maintenant ce n'est l'ennemi
si je réponds oui non non non et dire
non non je trouve que vous l'avez bien
présente et je vous emmerde evra est
bien présente on a le droit de ne pas
adhérer
moi je suis tellement pour la liberté
d'expression je m'aime pour le droit à
l'injure oui oui je préfère qu'un
journaliste 10-15 mensonge et qui
n'arrête pas de dire une vérité je vais
pas justifier ce que je vais dire
maintenant parce que je connais bien la
lan d'abord parce que j'étais ado
j'allais voir quand il chantait sous les
chapiteaux à l'époque
et puis ils étaient très bons comédiens
aussi dans un affrontement avec
jean-pierre mais bon évidemment il a les
défauts et les connaît les défauts
d'alan il s'emporte facilement est un
peu parfois je garde locale vous avez pu
vous en portez un peu facilement est-ce
que c'est pas un peu de la provoc quand
même d'appeler ça megalopolis des canaux
avec la lame écoutez moi j'ai déjà écrit
tous les articles
mégalo francis un machin ou faux bond ce
que je veux dire c'est que c'est pas moi
qui écris le titre et megalopolis on va
faire un peu d'étymologie à plus de
grecs police et la ville mégalo
reconnaissait sa grande villa
c'est un résultat bon et de toute façon
le regard des autres n'engage que que
qu'eux-mêmes et le regard des autres
moines pas au-devant des du critique
avec ce titre là la laitue et non mais
écoutez on quand on fait ce métier on va
au devant des critiques mais on va au
devant de droit qui sont bien plus
immense que les petits des plaisirs que
peuvent nous causer la presse
je passais souvent à côté du théâtre ou
en français ce jeune joueur
l'affrontement c'est quelqu'un qui va au
devant des choses c'est l'importance
qu'ils écoutent et ses galeries qui
alors je sais pas comment l'appeler
s'appelle affrontements j'ai jamais vu
c'est pas le flatter pascal bouquet
baird
comment s'est passée pas un principe à
ce sujet merde un compliment
alors ce livre s'appelle eliane ou idéal
était grave à mouazé vous dites qu il
faut lire une page juste avant de faire
l'amour à chaque fois oui enfin je
regarde le nombre de passes et moi quand
même jour serait dû au net sans ya cent
poèmes non mais c'est un conseil moi je
pense que l'amour il a l'amour charnel
et mon charnelle a aussi besoin de mots
et je pense que les poètes c'est leur
rôle de donner des maux au plaisir aussi
pendant ça dépend avec bien sûr et puis
depuis sept ans vous étiez roi j'ai fait
bien des choses là l'amendement
interruption de la baisse d'activité de
chanteur est dû avant tout au fait que
j'ai eu un procès avec une maison de
disques dont kim a interdit pendant des
années puisqu'il a duré sept ans cinq
ans exactement m'interdit de
d'enregistrer et donc c'est pour ça que
j'ai pas pu le faire donc j'ai développé
d'autres choses j'ai développé la
littérature j'ai publié des livres de
poèmes j'en ai j'en ai dit et d'autres
j'ai à développer la dramatique puisque
j'ai joué pendant trois ans avec jean
piat de saison à paris et puis une
tournée en province
et puis j'ai gagné mon procès est donc
maintenant ça me permet de pouvoir
prétendre jusqu'à ce que je suis en
train de faire en français pour moi en
espagnol aussi pour une tournée que je
vais faire en amérique du sud et
j'enregistre également l'album du
spectacle megalopolis qui sera versé en
trois albums dont jean drapeau vous que
vous êtes occupé des petites figurines
aussi alors j'ai également pendant cette
période
relancer une entreprise dans le périgord
qu une région que de vous reconnaitre je
cuisine ne les connais bien quitter
l'entreprise
fleury n'ont pas encore trouvé chaussure
à leur pied
je veux dire beaucoup de respect pour
roland dumas je veux dire voilà et
simplement annoncé son décès c'est une
entreprise qui tue votre côté asocial sa
part dont dire que quand roland soutient
christine ça va être d'accord là dessus
quand roland dumas dit le présent
république que pu être attaqué et
vraiment aux ou chirac peut pas être
embêté sur les hlm de paris
et quand roland dumas pour pas être
emmerdé sur elle qui donne chirac la
possibilité de ne pas être attaqué sur
les la mairie de paris les national de
paris vous n'allez pas me dire qu'enfin
franchement c'est pas bien un type comme
vous un type honnête comme puisse vous
répondre moi parce que je serais curieux
de connaître votre réponse au dessus moi
je vis le désert du monde me serre la
main
chirac et du mas disons merci et que
c'est la plus belle une du monde que
j'ai vu depuis longtemps douté moi je
vais vous dire une chose je n'ai jamais
été en accord avec les thèses du
gouvernement que défendent et roland
dumas
je les ai combattu j'ai payé le prix
pour ça mais jusqu'à preuve du contraire
je crois que l'on peut combattre
quelqu'un en tout cas combattre les
idées de quelqu'un et le respecter bon
alors il avait quelque chose
les rares il a de la sympathie coran
l'angola
moi j'en ai aussi beaucoup je suis
cependant d'accord avec vous sur le
conseil constitutionnel je trouve que ça
peut vraiment un problème soupçonné à ce
point les décisions sur conseil
constitutionnel mais juste la question
roland dumas c'est formidable quand même
dans un pays comme le nôtre à quel point
à un moment donné on a le sentiment
qu'on ne peut plus dire du bien de
quelqu'un pour ils ont immédiatement
être soupçonnée du pire
je suis absolument pour cette enquête
elle jusqu'au cou et d'un autre côté
c'est votre formidable qu'on puisse dire
qu'on adversaires d'ali bongo ondimba
parce que c'est un type formidable
s'il a fait des choses que la loi
réprouve et bien qu'il soit puni mais
c'est quand même je vais bien que c'est
quelqu'un qui passe quand même pas si
souvent que ça dans les médias la nan
parce que dans l'ensemble à l'acheter
c'est quand même un moment donné de se
dire oh de toute façon je vais pas me
compromettre tout le monde tape ce
roland dumas je vais faire pareil très
bien s'est vu céder
john cornyn qui mène au score qui m'est
arrivé c'est le cycliste orages vous
avez déclaré c'est une histoire à la
omar m'a tuer ce qui leur a continué
brièvement comment vous avez l'histoire
comment vous l'avez vécu dix ans j'ai
bien oui apparemment vous avez un beau
sourire bien sûr malheureusement c'est
ce qu'on a toujours appris que
l'essentiel c'est de boire manger de
respirer mais mais al omar m'a tuer
parce que j'ai suivi la dernière fois
son son histoire c'est vraiment en plus
quand j'explique les impôts ça c'est
c'est comme si comme accusé d'un meurtre
disons qu'aujourd'hui que je me retrouve
en inde c'est vraiment et c'est ça le
pire c'est que c'est d'un côté les
heureusement qu'on a les médias mais à
cause des médias les gens qui savent que
je suis innocent n'ont pas voulu
millions sont et ce qu'ils auraient
perdu de la crédibilité
mais il ya un mot qu'on n'a pas utilisée
aussi c'est la mentalité c'est ça c'est
que en france une drôle de mentalité et
quand je parle de la france il faut pas
dire oui tu es français oui je suis
fière d'être française les français mais
on est mauvaise mentalité
la ministre qui est arrivé et qui veut
faire parler d'elle j'trouve attendait
de moi laissez moi finir parce que c'est
dans les bons coups c'est un non c'est
pas vite faire puisque celle ci je dis
ça c'est que c'est bien notre rôle de
file c'est bien sûr je suis un et promis
à lutter contre le dopage contre le
sport mais là une façon de le faire
c'est à dire arriver en france
essayer de casser les cyclistes sachant
que là vous expliquer pas par rapport à
la mentalité c'est que dans le cyclisme
tous les français le savent c'est ça se
passe comme ça
les partenaires de ça le monde entier
tout d'un coup soit disant on sort un
gros c'est comme ça en voulant casser
tout le monde pourquoi on se ment on me
dira que son dopage en prépa tour de
france en plein jour
je sais pas comment mais chez nous d'une
solution c'est noté devient ne sont pas
faux cul parce qu'on sait tous que dira
qu un chien faut arrêter aussi sauf moi
nous sommes évoquées c'est aussi parce
que je dois vite ou vous même
tout le monde sait que tous les coureurs
sont dopés alors pourquoi lui bloqué
bonne ce qui est fou ou n'est pas tous
les ans 10 mois gériatrique j'ai rien à
dire non mais là c'est là où il a fait
une connerie mais non mais quand il est
neuf et sa connerie lui à sac du tombe
sur la tête
donc c'est difficile de quoi moi si
j'avais été à sa place je pense j'en
sais rien moi j'aurais pu dénoncer non
je m'en fous moi je n'en souffre
c'est simple mais que que lui et je sais
pas alors n'y a plus de foyers
il n'y a pas eu cette force vous fait
pas il a été mal conseillé
certains portaient vraiment dupe et oh
je sais pas c'est clair que vous appelez
m oui c'est vraiment ça on avait
l'impression il a raison ce n'est pas la
radio on avait l'impression d'un garçon
qui était marionnettes avec un avocat
qu'utilisait faut dire ça ça passage il
a misé sur la mauvaise ou maison
versement bussereau trop c'est trop il
faut savoir s'excuser je pense qu'ils
ont été trop loin très bien christian